[Music]
on this Wednesday night getting out of
Gaza the gates to Egypt finally open to
some
briefly I couldn't believe it last night
when we got a call who got out who is
still stuck we hear from Canadians whose
anxiety is building as Israel's prime
minister warns of a long harsh War her
son fulfilled his dream to Serve and
Protect well he was 16 and he joined the
Manitoba woman named this year's Silver
Cross
mother and if only the right Brothers
could see how far we've come when a new
electric aircraft will soar over
Canada global national with Donna
freezen good evening and thanks for
joining us for the first time in almost
a month people have been able to leave
Gaza which has been under siege and
bombardment by Israel since October 7th
they are the lucky few more than 300
foreign Nationals were allowed to leave
through the Rafa Crossing into Egypt
among them Americans and British people
it's not believed any Canadians crossed
and about 81 severely injured
Palestinians got out today taken for
medical treatment in Egypt for the
second day in a row Israel hit the
largest refugee camp in Gaza with air
strikes Hamas says dozens were killed
and injured Israel insists it is
targeting only Hamas commanders and
Fighters today the UN Human Rights
office said given the high number of
Civilian casualties and the scale of
Destruction it has serious concerns the
attacks could amount to war
crimes Israel's prime minister said
today the war will be long and harsh and
tonight the IDF confirms 16 Israeli
soldiers have been killed in Gaza
Danielle hamam Jin begins our coverage
tonight in a warning some of the images
in her story are
disturbing Israel has control over who
and what comes in and out of
Gaza after more than 3 weeks of Siege
sperman and waiting for medical
treatment they thought would never
come this was the moment the gates
finally opened allowing the first group
of injured Palestinians to cross into
Egypt the agreement mediated by catar
also allows certain foreign passport
holders to leave
Gaza Egyptian border guards were given a
list of about 500 people among the lucky
ones was likely R Hussein of
Jordan I couldn't believe it last night
when we got a call from Jordanian
officials at 2:30 in the morning she
said they told us we were getting out
Manar far also a Jordanian lost 76
members of his extended
family I've been here for nearly a month
each day waiting for death as houses
around us are destroyed he
said families sleeping in each other's
arms to
survive or die together the images are
horrifying foreign journalists continue
to be barred from entering Gaza we are
less than a kilometer away from Gaza we
can see the skyline and we can certainly
hear the non-stop shelling of The
Enclave occasionally we are also hearing
gunfire
Israel's ground operation is advancing
but doesn't appear to have entered
densely populated areas
yet many of those with a foreign
passport are done waiting on the other
side of the besieged territory a
Canadian woman took a chance our
Canadian embassy didn't contact due to
the bad Network Services they there's no
they can't contact us um but we heard
yesterday that the borders will be
opening at 7: a.m. so we came here
hoping to leave but it doesn't seem like
she made it through and neither did any
of the other Canadians or permanent
residents still trapped in Gaza and
there could be hundreds Donna Danielle
Hamin in Jerusalem thanks prime minister
Justin Trudeau reiterated today that
while Israel has a right to defend
itself the price of Justice he says
shouldn't be the continued suffering of
Palestinian civilians he called again
for a humanitarian pause in the attacks
we're calling on the liberation of
hostages on Aid to flow in and on uh
Canadians and their families to get out
of Gaza through the Rafa cross civilians
in Gaza have been deprived of food water
and medicine for almost a month because
of Israel's Siege though a trickle of
truckloads of Aid are getting through it
is far from enough Mike Armstrong on the
deepening humanitarian
crisis even with bombs fall falling and
fires burning in Gaza Hamas says it's
Israeli soldiers who are drowning in
sand in a statement the group's
political leader says the Israeli
hostages they are holding are exposed to
the same destruction and death as his
people now there are mediated
negotiations over the hostages but Hamas
says Israel would have to stop its
operations immediately the Israeli Prime
Minister is again making it clear that's
not going to
happen Benjamin Netanyahu warned the
country Wednesday this will be a tough
and long War according to the Israeli
military in the last 2 days 15 of its
soldiers have been killed but operations
haven't slowed there are in fact reports
of a new explosion in the jabalia area
of Gaza that's the same area hit Tuesday
by Israeli air
strikes the Israel Defense Forces say
the target of those air strikes was a
senior Hamas Commander killed along with
other members of the group hiding in a
civilian area that is information Global
News cannot confirm but it's clear there
were civilian
casualties AB kareim lost his entire
family 15 people he holds up a paper
with their names they were innocent he
says and
kind we've been trying to find people
but we can't this man says there's no
equipment and no civil defense
teams another thing there is little of
space this woman is caring for her son
in a school with hospitals full a
classroom was what was
left we're waiting she says there are no
treatments we were told they will send
him to Egypt but the roads are closed
getting around and getting out is the
goal for the 460 Canadians and family
members who are stuck in Gaza and in
contact with the Canadian government
there is no word on when Canadians will
leave this is Palestinian Canadian AIA
Mur she's been unable to leave with her
husband and two children the family's
not going to the Egyptian border yet
because she says Canada's Global Affairs
can't confirm they'll get through
they're basically telling me that they
cannot guarantee my uh safety or they
cannot guarantee that I would be able to
cross now there is a trickle of Aid
making it into Gaza about 14 trucks a
day they normally get about 400 trucks a
day the aid is moving in from Egypt
after a deal was struck with Israel for
the vehicles to be inspected before
going in now there is one thing
complicating the distribution of that
desperately needed Aid according to the
UN it's their Logistics base in Rafa
right now it has about 8,000 displaced
people Sheltering in it Donna Mike
Armstrong thanks many of the family
members of the more than 200 people
being held hostage by Hamas and Gaza
want Israel to make the safety of those
hostages the top priority our Mike dret
spoke with some of their relatives in
Toronto who say they take issue with
Israel's response uh must be insanely
difficult it's time stopped I I don't
understand my own feelings I this is the
last place Aaron broish wants to be
talking about his sister-in-law niece
and two nephews is gut-wrenching yet
it's keeping him sane you know he's just
a cute four-year-old I mean he's four
yeah um you know he likes playing soccer
mostly in the house telling stories
about them he says puts a human face to
what is otherwise a grim and
dispassionate
number more than 200 people still held
hostage in Gaza by Hamas and now after
weeks of an intense and deadly Israeli
response the families of the hostages
are openly questioning if the strategy
will see results we realized immediately
that we have to start um putting
pressure on the Israeli
government uh to make this their
priority um you know not not one of the
priorities of the war not the top
priority of the war but the only
priority um do you feel that's being
done I I feel that it's been 24 days and
they're not back so no to that end
families of the hostages have been on a
tour of major media markets around the
world looking for political and
influential allies last week I was uh
with a delegation in
Madrid what they need they say is help a
country like Canada that can bridge the
gap between Hamas and Israel and
negotiate the return of the
hostages I think to have an intermediate
is crucial right
now and that is the only way to to bring
Sol uh to bring a quick solution that
will help all civilians in in uh in the
region it has nothing to do with the war
it has nothing to do with choosing sides
it's a humanitarian issue that needs to
be solved immediately kids can't survive
in captivity yet here we are with kids
on both sides of the conflict caught in
the middle Mike tray Global News Toronto
a rebel group in Yemen admits it
launched missile and drone attacks on
Southern Israel on Tuesday the houi
militia backed by Iran says it is
reacting to what it calls brutal
aggression in Gaza Yemen is a small
desert country on the Arabian Peninsula
it's about 2,000 kilometers away from
Israel the houthis took over Yemen's
capital in 2014 and Rule much of the
country's North McKenzie gray looks at
how they could play a role in a wider
regional
conflict these Rockets could signal a
new entrance into the Israel Hamas
conflict they were fired by Iranian
backed houthi rebels in Yemen shot at
the southern Red Sea Resort city of alad
leading Israeli fighter jets in the
aerody defense system to shoot them down
before they reached Israeli
airspace AA forces identified an aerial
Target a spokesperson said alert sounded
and there was no
threat but the larger threat and ended
conflict with other Regional powers like
Hezbollah and Lebanon who are also
backed by Iran a scenario the US has
warned against as the president has made
clear as the secretary has made clear
anyone that's um uh considering joining
this conflict uh in opposition to Israel
should think again their slogan is death
to America death to Israel death to the
Jews so that tells you a lot the hou's
chilling motto could best be executed
not through attacks in Israel but on
commercial shipping and that could
potentially lead to higher oil prices
the most important thing in the southern
part of the Arabian Peninsula is the
movement of uh oil and and natural gas
uh through the Gulf of Aiden and up the
Red Sea the ability of the houis to
really do anything significant against
Israel is very limited the former US
ambassador to Yemen believes the houthis
could escalate the conflict by directly
attacking oil fields in Saudi Arabia a
country they've been fighting since 2014
are they successful in that would
obviously also have a huge impact on
global economies Iran warned that if the
bombing in Gaza doesn't stop the houthi
rebels would continue to expand their
operations against Israel Donna okay
McKenzie gray thank you immigration has
been fueling record population growth
here in Canada and today the federal
immigration Minister said he is aiming
to keep the plan Target of adding
485,000 immigrants in 2024 raising it to
500,000 in 2025 and then keeping it at
half a million the following year he
says Ottawa is trying to align its
policy with the labor needs of Canada
these immigration levels allow us to
bring in the skills and talent we need
to fill the labor gaps and ensure
Canada's economic prosperities help
families reunite and remain a leader in
Refugee resettlement they're keeping us
with our long-term focus on economic
growth more than a million Afghan
refugees are facing deportation from
Pakistan and some of them want to come
to Canada they fled to Pakistan when the
Taliban returned to power in Afghanistan
in 2021 Tria isri has the story of some
of them waiting for Canada to process
their Refugee
applications Pakistan has started
rounding up undocumented Afghans and
searching for those in hiding like
hashmat sahill and St here is also like
a prison he worked alongside Canadian
troops as a contractor in
Kandahar he fled to neighboring Pakistan
after the Taliban seized control in
August 2021 sahill and his family are
waiting desperately for Canada to
process their Refugee applications it
really hurts us sahill shared his story
with global news reporter shagufa Danish
her family also escaped to Pakistan and
could be sent back to Taliban controlled
Afghanistan the work that I did before
in Afghanistan and the work that I'm
doing right now here is putting my
family more in danger Global News
received an email immigration refugees
and citizenship Canada sent to Afghan
migrants trying to come here any ircc
client who has been detained in Pakistan
should notify the high Commission of
Canada in Pakistan the immigration
Minister acknowledges that's unrealistic
I'm very concerned about particularly
our particularly our clients that we
made commitments to who's being left
behind the people who served Canada and
they left once Canada has taken in
40,000 Afghan refugees since 2021 it's
not clear how many Afghans who helped
Canada are now in Pakistan and waiting
for their Refugee applications to be
processed the immigration Ministry says
it can't reveal those numbers because of
security
concerns teria isri Global News
Ottawa how to regulate Artificial
Intelligence coming up why at least one
AI expert says getting China involved
is
crucial some of the biggest names in
Tech including Elon Musk are in the UK
for a summit on artificial intelligence
AI is developing faster than governments
can keep up it has the potential to
improve our lives and also potentially
control Our Lives Crystal ganing
explains what this UK Summit is focused
on and why Bletchley Park is where code
crackers engage with new technology to
learn enemy Secrets during the second
world war A fitting location for world
leaders today looking to manage Frontier
artificial intelligence I firmly believe
that we must be guided by a common set
of understandings among nations the
United States and other partners of
Canada's and the 5is intelligence
Alliance signed on to The Bletchley
declaration a total of 28 countries are
in agreement about the need to
understand and collectively manage
potential AI risks including China the
chief AI officer at Western University
in Ontario says China's involvement is
key some of the top AI labs and top AI
researchers are located in China and so
having them as part of that conversation
is absolutely essential if we really
want a global set of principles in terms
of the potential harmful side of the
technology there are fears of cyber
attacks even biological weapons so
agreed National rules are necessary in
terms of other avenues of regulations
it's early days I don't know what
necessarily the fair rules are but
you've got to start with Insight before
you do oversight Canada's minister of
innovation science and technology is at
the two-day Gathering and took to social
media writing Canada is a leader in safe
and responsible AI development through
International collaboration we will be
able to move the world from Fear to
opportunity on AI Canada is one of the
creators of this technology and we have
huge capacity in terms of of the
research infrastructure and the the
startup and corporate infrastructure so
this is a real economic engine for our
country the financial benefits are not
lost on the UK government by
highlighting its past at the Forefront
of technology and hosting the first of
its kind World AI safety Summit it's
hoping to once again be seen as a leader
Crystal Ganson Global News
London still ahead the electric vertical
takeoff and Landing aircraft set to
takeoff in
[Music]
Canada the future of flight could be
electric and a Canadian Helicopter
Company is betting on it vancouver-based
hel jet will soon add electric vertical
takeoff and Landing aircraft or eveve
tolls to its Fleet it's the first
Canadian airline to place orders for a
cuttingedge EV toll made by
vermont-based Beta Technologies Neu Gara
explains what it can
do a silent aircraft taking to the Skies
part of the first Frontier for electric
Aviation HED to hit Canadian airspace
within a few years so 2028 I would say
is probably a realistic date that we
could see a vehicle here on the ramp the
pilots can control the maneuverability
of these props as well as this rear prop
to give it forward speed and move
forward vancouver-based helicopter
Airline heli jet placed what president
and CEO Danny sitam says is Canada's
first order for an electric vertical
takeoff aircraft taking a big step
forward in disrupting Aviation if you
will it's built by a vermont-based
manufacturer with an office in Montreal
the tech company says they're focused on
reducing the footprint in all aspects of
the supply chain let acid B batteries
are the most recycled consumer product
in the world we see a similar path
developing around lithium batteries and
heli Jet's hope is also to use these
electric planes for its helicopters
Without Borders initiative serving Rural
and remote indigenous communities what
more can we do with these new
technologies it's even at a lower cost
at a lower noise footprint not to
disrupt the communities where we can do
like a milk run right and and stop at
all the communities in one day and keep
keep the cost down the aircraft which
can carry five passengers and One Pilot
is currently undergoing regulatory tests
BC's Premier called it an Innovative
response to climate change n Gara Global
News Richmond
BC a silver cross mother necks the heavy
burden she's honored to
Bear every year the Canadian Legion
chooses someone to represent all the
mother whose children have died in
Conflict this year it's Gloria Hooper
whose son Chris was the first Canadian
Peacekeeper to die in Bosnia in 1996 far
Nasser has her
story Gloria Hooper is a mother morning
not just a loss but a sense of
possibilities her oldest son Chris jipen
would have been 50 this month I'm just
thinking I used to see those all the
time all over the place all over the
house
peacekeeping patches memories of his
missions and I finally made him take
everything into the bedroom since Chris
was a young boy military memorabilia
covered Gloria's Manitoba home he wanted
to join the Army as long as she can
remember oh he was 16 and he joined a
reservist at first After High School
Chris went on to two peacekeeping
missions Cyprus and Croatia he loved
that he just loved
especially where there were kids then at
22 Chris was deployed to the Bosnian
warfront as a combat engineer where he
would organize a donation drive for
children there cuz he said they didn't
have clothes you must have been proud of
them I was cuz he was but it was just
that it he was young I didn't want him
there so young and I thought well if
he's there for a while he'll be back oh
sure
on July 4th 1996 on route to rescue a
group of British soldiers stranded in a
Minefield Chris was killed when his
armored vehicle similar to this one
crashed his casket landed in Canada 7
Days Later the day he was due to return
home so instead of coming home as a
person he came home and a as a body and
I know when they brought
and they said well you can't see
him because he's two so just remember
what he was like before the government
of Manitoba named a lake in his honor
I've never gone there yet but she does
come
here the senat half where her son's name
sits just above the names of those lost
in the first and second world war cuz he
was the last one they ever put and
sitting beside it a tiny toy soldier
they took Gloria by surprise and back in
time he always had those with him he
just bring them with him yep Gloria
tells us she's now forgetting things she
lives with dementia but loves to talk
about Chris do the memories become more
have they become more foggy is it hard
no no not at all really yeah your
memories of him are crystal clear
yeah it's funny it's the power of a
mother's love I know it's just
unbelievable I would just love to be
able to see him now she likes to think
he can see her wearing her Silver Cross
medal on Remembrance Day she'll be
representing all military parents laying
a wreath in Ottawa far Asser Global News
St Claude
Manitoba our final word tonight is about
one of our own dorana temo a global
national original who was part of the
small team that launched this newscast
back back in 2001 died early this
morning from breast cancer she was 64
doriana was a Trailblazer starting in
journalism in the late 7s when it was
dominated by men she worked as a
reporter an anchor and our news director
before retiring in 2016 she was a mentor
and a friend to many of us she taught us
to keep pushing at barriers never give
up and keep looking forward dorian's
deepest devotion was to her husband
children and grandchildren and our
thoughts are with her family tonight
thanks for
[Music]
watching